immer mehr menschen arbeiten bei uns auf
abruf oder müssen mehrere jobs machen
reden wir darüber mit dem heute show
wirtschaftsweisen sebastian pufpaff
verpufft wie flexibel soll unsere arbeit
eigentlich noch werden erstmal flexibel
das ist also ich finde das ist eines der
schönsten worte überhaupt flexibel das
ist beweglich elastisch biegsam machen
sie auch mal probieren sie mal auf st
flex lipide in anspruch und ganz ehrlich
warum denn nicht mehrere jobs auch viele
politiker haben zwei jobs bundestag und
aufsichtsrat
weil es sonst nicht reicht oder sie
werke gutes beispiel
sie machen hier diesen kasper kram und
betreut zusätzlich noch altersschwache
torhüter
wobei es ja auch gut ist nicht er ist ja
sonst auf dem arbeitsmarkt überhaupt
nicht mehr zu vermitteln sowie ist doch
quatsch betreut ihn überhaupt nicht
außerdem kann der oli inzwischen schon
ganz viele sachen alleine bild seien sie
mal nicht so bescheiden mein lieber na
ja wir brauchen totale flexibilität
tschuldigung der kollege von den
wirtschaftsweisen hat vollkommen zu
recht gesagt zitat es muss möglich sein
dass man nach feierabend noch an einer
telefon konferenz teilnimmt und morgens
beim frühstück seine mails liest und da
hat er recht ja warum in unserer
sogenannten freizeit nicht noch was weg
arbeiten beispiel toilette tote zeit
tote zeit kann ich super nes skype
konferenz machen oder hier hat genau wie
beim pflicht bis samstags macht der
sportschau warum nicht gleichzeitig ein
paar wichtige mails verantworten
ja ja ja ich sage mir immer du wenn ihre
frau dafür kein verständnis hat dann
zeigt das nun mal wieder dass sie die
arbeitswelt nicht kapiert wir merken uns
herr job nein
kommt ihr super an aber
ja sie wissen wie man sich benimmt macht
aber wo soll das denn noch hinführen ich
sag mal h&m h&m ist ein gutes beispiel
da arbeiten jetzt schon 41 prozent der
beschäftigten auf abruf dh die kriegen
weil sie nicht zehn stunden die woche
garantiert müssen aber die ganze zeit am
telefon warten ob der chef sie
vielleicht brauche ich ja kommen sie
aber das ist doch herrlich
also ich zum beispiel ich träume von
einer welt in der ich als arbeitgeber
jederzeit jeden anrufen kann und der
muss mir dann die regale einräumen
auch ihr gejammer welke nicht nervt in
der kantine dieses ewige ich will abends
heim zur familie
keiner sieht mehr seine familie nie
punkt so und und alle meiner meinung
nach alle sollten mindestens 23 gern
auch acht jobs seit zwei monaten hat sie
drei jobs nach abzug der fixkosten
bleiben ihr 750 euro
dafür arbeitet sie 60 stunden die woche
ja klar
das klingt aber wenn du 60 stunden
arbeitet hast du gar keine zeit das geld
auszugeben dass du nicht verdienst das
ist wohin ruin
aber was ich mich gerade frage warum ist
diese flexibilität eigentlich immer nur
eine einbahnstraße also was hat denn der
arbeitnehmer davon was meinen sie jetzt
ja was was bekommt der arbeitnehmer als
gegenleistung
da verstehe ich die frage meine mehr
flexibilität sollte doch auch mehr geld
auf dem gehaltszettel bedeuten ja ich
glaube da kann ich ihnen jetzt auch also
das müssen sie anders formulieren das
macht doch nix sebastian dorf badama
[Applaus]